what is that professor
it is a historic artifact so i was doing
a bit of clearing out the other day and
i found this this is from 1989 it is
what used to be called a pre-print so
when you wrote a paper it took a while
for it to actually appear in print
submit the paper it will get referees so
it would get looked at it will get
assessed and then it will be accepted
for publication but the time between a
paper being accepted and getting printed
back then was you know maybe six months
and so what you do is once a paper was
accepted you produce one of these things
called free print
and your institutions are at that point
i was at the harvard smithsonian center
for astrophysics they had a mailing list
that they'd send copies of these out to
other astronomical institutions around
the world and also
once a paper was accepted for
publication people would get to know
that the paper existed and you'd
actually people would send you postcards
saying please can you send me a copy of
this paper and you send them one of
these a pre-print of it so this is the
thing that now there's this electronic
thing called archive which essentially
does the same thing that allows you to
disseminate your results before they get
you know appear imprinted in uh in a
journal but this was this was kind of
the pre-archive version of what what a
uh pre-print looked like do you remember
whether or not you got many postcards i
do remember receiving some because i
remember being surprised when the first
one showed up in the post um but i don't
remember there being huge demand for
this paper honestly and what is it about
can you can you tell us about some
research it's called the distribution of
cluster members in the vicinity of a
central dominant galaxy so if you've got
a cluster of galaxies you often find
there's a very big bright galaxy in the
middle of it this thing called a central
dominant galaxy and then when you look
in more detail at those central dominant
galaxies you often find there are sort
of secondary knots condensations of
light within them either these are kind
of physically associated with that
central dominant galaxy and probably
there are other galaxies that are kind
of in the process of being cannibalized
by their kind of partially digested
galaxies that happen to crash into it
and are kind of merging with it or the
alternative is that they're just
galaxies that just happen to lie along
the same line of sight when they get
just in front of it or behind it and so
the point of this paper the motivation
for it was to try and figure out which
of those things was happening
and the way we did that was
essentially just to count the number of
galaxies as you go away from the center
to see how the number drops off as you
go away further and further away because
if you know if you know how that
number's dropping off you can kind of
extrapolate as to what should be
happening right in the middle and hence
how many things should just be there by
chance anyway essentially we ended up
averaging a whole bunch of clusters
together so there's not enough
information if you look at one cluster
there's maybe 20 or 30 galaxies it's
very hard from that very noisy
information to figure out how the
distribution goes with radius so what we
ended up doing was taking a dozen or so
clusters and kind of stacking the data
up together to see what the average
profile was i should say the answer by
the way was it's about if you want to
like say how many of those multiple
nuclei are just kind of the
extrapolation of that profile into the
center it's about half of them so it
looks like a good fraction of them
really are just kind of chance line of
sight things but but there is still an
over density of them that seem to be
physically associated with that central
galaxy i was phd student steve kent was
my phd supervisor so this was the first
piece of work that we did together who
should be getting the glory here i don't
i don't know where to apportion the
credit steve definitely so it was his
data the data already existed not that
long before this when people took
pictures they used photographic plates
and this was ccd data so this was using
modern detectors
like you know the clients in modern
video cameras and it was quite
innovative to use ccd data at that point
so i was using kind of the you know the
cutting edge data that was available at
the time but steve had actually taken it
he made the observations and he kind of
said well here's a load of data you can
play around with so it was kind of the
first project he gave me to play with
what's it like when you have your first
paper accepted for a publication it's
very exciting yeah i was yes and
actually the first time i saw a little
bit before the paper was accepted i gave
my first seminar about it i gave a talk
about it which was just an internal talk
at the center for astrophysics but the
center for astrophysics was kind of a
scary place in that there are you know
250 phd astronomers including some you
know really big names in astronomy so i
was a bit terrified given my first ever
talk about my own research but i gave
this talk and afterwards steve came up
to me afterwards and said take the rest
of the day off so i know i've done all
right or he was sheltered
when you read it now i mean has this
research been superseded does it still
hold water would you do things
differently i mean there's loads more
data by a complete coincidence i have a
phd student at the moment that i'm
supervising who
as kind of a side project to her main
project he's essentially doing this
research again but with much better data
because now there is you know there are
images of large chunks of the sky there
are these huge surveys that you can just
tap into and get the data from she she
will actually hopefully reproduce the
whole show that i was wrong one or the
other
there's something mildly alarming about
the red color of the cover was that
standard practice or just a choice by
harvard smithsonian i think it was just
them every every different institution
had had its own covers that it had made
so after i was here i was an
organization called sita the canadian
institute for theoretical astrophysics
and they actually had cardboard covers
with a little cutout and so you had to
make sure that your title and name
appeared in exactly the right place on
the front page of the of the paper so
that it would show through the little
cutout in the in the cover but yeah it
was one of those things each institution
had its own covers you said you stumbled
over it while you were doing a clear out
did you
sit back on the sofa and read the whole
thing again or i did yeah
i wrote quite well even then
[Laughter]
did you find any typos i know
it stands up quite well it was quite
well written what helped was so this was
the first paper you go through this
process if you write a paper you submit
it to a journal and then it gets sent
out to a referee who actually assesses
it and comes back with their you know
whether it's publishable or not whether
there's any changes you want to make so
this is my first paper and i had a
really nice referee who actually sent
back an annotated copy of your
manuscript with all my typos and things
indicated on it so i actually had that
to help me make sure that the version
that finally got printed and the version
that ended up in the preprint hopefully
had all the typos taken out i always
thought writing these papers you were
supposed to be quite dry and there was
almost like a template to follow can you
express any
writing ability in a scientific paper i
think so and you have to right because
you want it to be readable you know
you're right it has to you know there
are certain conventions there are
certain ways that you say things but
nonetheless you want it to be
sufficiently kind of engaging that the
person reading it doesn't give up and
actually keeps reading it and actually
you know you want to sell your science
right you actually want to convince
somebody your results are right
and that what you've done is interesting
and you you can only do that if you
write reasonably well because if you
write really badly no one's going to
understand what you're trying to say and
they're not going to kind of feel any
particular need to read to the end of it
so it is you know it's part of the
process and actually it's sort of my
favorite part of science is writing
papers i really enjoy that that kind of
skill of writing papers can good or even
great discoveries be lost to science
because they were poorly written up i
guess we'll never know
unless there was a really good one that
was undiscovered for 20 years and then
someone was like oh my goodness this
person discovered this they just wrote
it poorly but that's probably true and
you know and it it is also true that
different scientists you know as i say i
really enjoy that part of the process
quite a lot of my colleagues view it as
a bit of a chore they'd rather be doing
the science i actually really like
writing about the science explaining the
science so in that sense i'm quite a
useful collaborator for some of my
colleagues because some of them are much
more interested in doing the you know
doing the actual research and the
analysis and then they'll leave it up to
me to actually you know turn it into
into the english that will explain it
but it's the fun part as far as i'm
concerned
that's grand design spiral structure
here we have the other extreme which is
this stuff called flocculant spiral
structure you know you can't pick out
two arms here there's just lots of
little tiny bits of spiral structure and
here we think there might be a different
piece of physics as to what's going on
so in this case we've got the center of
our galaxy and what we think probably
happens in systems like this is some
stars start to form at some point